so today we are going to be talking
about running notebooks in production
right maybe you heard this before um
there are a few companies that do this
that run roblox in production
and i think when i share this with
other data scientists or other
practitioners many get the idea that
this is like something crazy
and that you should never do it right um
there are good reasons for
not carelessly deploying notebooks into
production but i think it's important to
get into the details like
i understand why some people don't like
this idea um but why there are others
who actually promote these and and why
what's what's the way of promoting this
like what's the reasoning
um so we are gonna go through all this
this important stuff and all these
details right um are you you may if
you've been doing data science or data
analytics for a while
um and you have used jupyter notebooks
you know that
if you start working on a notebook
things become a mess really fast right
you start adding a few sales you start
adding some code um and then all of a
sudden maybe a few days of working with
your notebook um it's like 200 sales and
then things break and then you cannot
reproduce your results
but we can actually use jupyter
notebooks in a maintainable way and we
can develop high quality production
ready code and this is what this talk
will try to convince you about so
hopefully it will um
give you the tools to try it by yourself
and see that that it works
now uh before i continue there's
actually a really interesting there's a
really interesting use case from
evadation health a healthcare technology
company they use notebooks in production
and you can see it by yourself um
there's there's a link here you can look
at their use case to see a real industry
use case of notebooks in production and
we're going to cover many of the things
that they do in this talk
all right
now before i start there is something
really really important to know because
i feel like whenever
we whenever the people who
um advocate to run notebooks in
production like me
this is like the most important thing to
mention because many of the discussion
turns around this idea and this fact
jupiter is actually two things it's a
file format and it's a platform and it's
important to study these
from
this angle where we take into account
both
both parts of the equation
when you are working on a jupyter
notebook you are storing this type of
file this the ipi and b format is
actually a json file so when you're
working on a typical jupyter notebook if
you open your notebook with a text
editor it's going to look like this
right
this is a json file with a specific
schema
and
this has some benefits and some
disadvantages one of the main benefits
is that you can
record the output of your code in a
single file then you can share this file
with someone else and then they'll be
able to see your charts everything that
you produce in your notebook without
having to rerun anything because your
notebook contains all of these things in
the same file
now it's also a platform because if you
take a notebook and open that file in
jupyter lab or the classic jupyter
notebooks you'll have all these buttons
and features that allow you to edit this
notebook
the important thing and this is like a
really uh
essential piece that i want to share is
that you can
use this independently and let me
explain that a little bit one of the
most important tricks to write clean
notebooks and use jupyter notebooks in
production is to just use a different
format and this is something that most
people don't know
um but this is this really changes a lot
of the the ideas
there's this package called jupitext
that allows you to
have different file formats that when
you open them they behave like a
notebook
one of the most popular
formats is this
pi file with specific annotations so
this is your typical dot by file except
it has a few extra marks you can see
this and you can see this
this special marker separates the
notebook the notebook um because this is
actually a notebook in pi format and
this you can use this marker to separate
different cells
right and you can use other formats up
text supports markdown
and many other formats so this this is
very important thing for you to know you
can use alternative formats and then you
can open them as jupiter networks now
what's the main benefit of this
if you're using git
then storing pi files
makes things a lot easier for you
because since i mentioned before the ipi
mv format contains output and many other
things
that make it a bit tricky to work with
git
it also helps with
interoperability because maybe you like
notebooks but maybe your colleague likes
vs code or spider or pycharm
all these ides can open this same format
so then if you like notebooks you can
open jupyter
change this file and then your colleague
can use vs code and edit the same file
all right
so now let's dive into the details so
this talk is um i split this talk into
three sections the first part is how do
you write clean notebooks how do we keep
the standards high
so we are able to reproduce our code
make our code readable and
make sure that when we come back to our
notebook we understand it now there's
also you'll see that i'm showing a lot
of links and there are a few recommended
reads
there's a longer version of this section
in our blog so you can go to plumber dot
io slash blog slash clean um
nbs and then you'll see like a longer
version of this
all right so
one of the first properties of clean
notebooks is that they are short if you
have a notebook that has three 400 sales
it's gonna be really really challenging
to maintain so the first thing is
keep your notebook short and follow the
same structure have a standard structure
so you understand what's going on and
other people understand what's going on
now what's that structure i don't want
to be too prescriptive i'm sharing
what's been working for me um through
the years but always if you have
questions if you feel like there's
something you can improve um you can
suggest things right that's that's
that's the spirit with all these
practices i'm gonna propose a few things
but maybe a few things don't work for
you so maybe you can you can tweak it a
little bit
okay this is the structure that i follow
with all my notebooks at the beginning i
have all my input statements essentially
all the libraries that i'm gonna use
even if i'm using one specific library
at the end of my notebook i put it i put
the import statement at the beginning
the reason is that if i open the
notebook then i'll know
what libraries i'm using if i put my
import statements in the middle of the
notebook then
maybe i'll start executing it and then
i'll realize that i don't have that
library so having these import
statements at the top kind of sets up
expectations of what libraries you are
going to use
the second important thing is the
configuration
often you have to prepare a few things
before running your code
for example if you are connecting to
some database you have to create the
database connection
this is just an example of other things
maybe you are logging your results it's
important to put all the configuration
in the same place and the reason is the
same if you open a notebook and you see
one cell with all the configuration then
you know what's going on right you know
that this notebook is um communicating
with some database it's logging the
experiments to an external server or any
other external thing that that you need
you can put that here
the next part is
the data loading if we are going to use
jupyter notebooks for for analyzing
clean data we have to load the data at
some point
and i recommend you put this right here
where someone who's reading the notebook
can see um
all the data that you are going to use
and then you repeat the same recipe once
you load the data you repeat the same
recipe
for all the sections you have markdown
heading a magnum heading is just some
text and then
you have some title where you can
quickly explain what's going on by just
one or two words then you can add
some text below to
explain what's gonna what this section
is gonna do then the takeaways kind of
the conclusion of what this section is
and finally the code so if you follow
this recipe you'll see that the code
becomes a lot clearer and easy to read
okay
now let's move on the second advice that
i have is in terms of the code
let me show you an example because
that's gonna
make things a lot easier
let's imagine that you you're using
pandas really popular library i'm sure
you have used it many many times
and you have a function right you know
that modularizing your code is important
so you have a function that performs
some transformation
in this case that transformation is
taking the serials column and adding one
like that's all it's doing it simply
adds one
and then you initialize your data you
load your data
so i'm passing um three zeros i'm naming
this column zeros
then assigning it to this data frame
now imagine you have a bunch of code
maybe a hundred lines of code
and then you have something like this
maybe you remember that your data frame
df has zeros
right
what happens if we run
this function
look at the implementation
and we are overwriting the values inside
the data frame
and when we print the value
we'll see that this actually contains
once
now this example is really really really
simple but when you have two maybe
200 lines of code it becomes really hard
to understand what's going on and it
might be surprising to you to see that
your data frame contains once instead of
zeros
the problem is that we are modifying
our argument so the argument of this
function is the f
and from here
we don't know if we are modifying the if
or we are doing something else
it's unclear what's going on we have to
look at the
implementation and this
can cause a lot of headaches
now how do we fix it
well we create immutable code that
doesn't change the arguments
look at the difference between the first
implementation and the second
implementation in the second one we are
copying the data and we are modifying
the copy of the data
so if we initialize our data and we
apply the transformation
once con contains the number one because
we are adding one but df contains zeros
right so if we still remember that we
loaded all serials
all throughout our notebook df will
still contain zeros no surprises
now of course this simple approach is
not feasible when you are dealing with
large data sets because coping data um
it's going to add a lot of overhead in
terms of the memory that you need
but for many cases it's it's it works
it's a simple approach that works if you
are dealing with big data sets then
there are other techniques that you can
follow
um in order to prevent this kind of um
this kind of surprises
great
uh now moving on
one important thing
about your code
is that most likely you're using
external libraries right you might be
using pandas numpy security learn and
these libraries change
scikit-learn that you use a month ago is
different from the one that you get if
you download the latest version
many times it will be fine and your code
will just work
but sometimes maintainers have to make
breaking changes
maybe people are suggesting that some
argument is confusing maybe they are
deprecating some apis
this the the bottom line is that
things may break like your notebook may
work fine just now but a few months from
now it will break with the same code
with the same data but different
versions
how do you protect against those those
changes
well you have to record all the versions
that you are using
so if you are using package a 1.1 and
package b 2.4 you want to record all
those things
so next time you try to run your code
you recover these
same versions and you run the code
with them and how do you do that well
once you install all your dependencies
you can run this command
and this is going to auto generate
all these lines
all these packages with all these
versions and now let's say uh three
months from now you share your notebook
with a colleague and then you send both
the notebook and this file
if they take this file and then use pip
install they'll be able to recreate your
environment and they will get the same
versions that you had
two three months ago
and you'll make sure that they are able
to run it
now this is like a really really simple
trick that works
really well it's just one command you
create a file and that's it
and if you change your dependencies
you can run it again
to get the new changes
all right
so we are almost done with the first
section um the latest part is about the
format when we are writing a bunch of
codes
especially in jupiter we may just be
typing things running some experiments
and at some point we are like okay this
is working this is the final version i
i'm gonna move on it on to a different
thing
your code your experimental code may
look like this
right a few lines here and over here um
maybe some white space over here
and it's a bit hard to read like it's
good that you are making those rapid
experiments
but if you come back to your notebook or
someone else reads your notebook
they will have a hard time
trying to understand this right and
making good use of white space in the
notebook helps a lot with
readability
now what you can do is how to format
your notebook meaning you pass a program
that takes the same code
and transform it to make it more
readable it's still the same code it's
gonna do the exact same thing
it's just that looks different
look at the example on on your right
it's the same code
except this one is passing one column
uh two data frame in one line of code
this should actually be uh c so x y c
and you can read that one line per
column makes a lot of sense because if
you look on the left it's kind of hard
to see
that you are going to create three
columns on your right it's easy to see
that you have x y and this other column
and this is just one of one example of
what these formatters do for you the
other thing is that if you agree and
this is just another specific example if
you are writing some if statements
you may break the logic into multiple
lines by using
the backlash
so the backslash you can put it here and
then you can break down this if
statement into multiple lines
it's a bit harder to read
and you can use parenthesis for that so
if you autoformat these things
you'll see that it automatically fits
this into a single line and if it's a
long if statement it will automatically
break break it down with parentheses
which is a lot more readable
now we don't have time to do these
things manually right we just want to
get things
working and then move on
you can use this package that we are
developing
and it will automatically do the
formatting for you
um this standard for formatting is
called black it's um
official
package um a package that
many many people in the python community
uses
um we just grabbed a wrapper that makes
it possible to use this formatter in
jupyter notebooks
all right
now
the last section the last part of this
section is splitting logic from
narrative the idea with notebooks is
that you are telling a story about your
data you are transforming your data you
are cleaning your data
and you're essentially doing a recipe
right step one step two step three
now some steps in that recipe might be
more complex than others
so we can split the code
into two different types the first one
is the logic
functions that encapsulate some steps
some logic and classes
that
encapsulate some some logic
and the narrative the narrative are all
the plots all the chains of
transformations and the story that we
are telling about our data
now if we split this into two
things become a lot more readable
because if someone
opens your notebook and they see the
story
they can quickly understand what's going
on at a high level for example you can
see that i'm loading some data here and
then i'm adding one i don't know exactly
what's the implementation of this
function but based on the name
i cannot guess what's going on
and then i can split my logic my
functions in a separate file
so i have a transformation.pi and i and
then i import this transformations.pi
into my notebook
so this display helps a lot for you
because you can test
the logic separately
and
also for your readers because you're
able to open the notebook and see kind
of the story so it's a little a little
bit of extra work because you have to
create a new file you have to move your
code into that separate file
but you'll see that um
you'll be able to create cleaner
notebooks and your code will be a lot
more readable
all right so that's the end of the first
section
now let's talk about testing notebooks
this um
testing notebooks is a lot more
challenging than you would expect
because
most of the time we are analyzing data
and if we analyze data and the data
changes
the the code may break right so we have
to take into account both the data and
the code
now if you are interested in taking a
deep dive into these two topics we have
two blog posts and i have the links
right here let's start with i'm gonna
mention three types of tests and those
have different objectives the first one
is testing outputs
when you run your notebooks some of the
cells may generate outputs
for example here i am training the model
and then i'm printing the accuracy of
that model so you see that this is 0.963
now imagine that i make a few changes to
my data set or my transformations and
then this turns out to be 0.8
if i'm running things manually
i'm gonna be surprised
i'm gonna be
surprised that this change too much and
then
i think this this this change is worth
investigating
um
when i'm analyzing data and see these
radical changes
i usually
go back and analyze my code see what i
change
and try to come up to a conclusion right
maybe it's right maybe maybe i just
added some data and my accuracy dropped
or maybe not maybe i introduced some
change
but this manual process takes a lot of
time
so we have a new package this is
something that we are working on an open
source package called mb snapshot that
allows you to capture these outputs
historically essentially every time you
run your notebook you can record
some outputs
and then you we can define an expected
range
in a normal let's think about this
accuracy score if you train your the
same model with the same data but
slightly different parameters or maybe
you have some randomness in your code
it's expected for these results to
change just a little bit so we use that
we use that variation and take it into
account to define unexpected range
so if your value falls inside that range
it's all good you can run your notebook
and it will be fine if it falls
out of the range then you'll see an
error and then you'll have the change
chance to investigate what's going on so
it's a way to automate
the manual checks that we still do
when we are running our code
so this is the first uh the first type
of testing testing the cell output the
the cell outputs
now the second one is highly efficient
because in some cases you are printing
some values like here
but in other cases you might be creating
new files
right
if you create new files it's important
to also test
those files and the most important
example here is data quality tests so
let's imagine that you have a notebook
and you are
you're cleaning some data
and then you store that clean data into
a
maybe
file
are making some assumptions about what
clean data means maybe for you the
definition of clean data is that column
is that
a specific column doesn't have any nas
or maybe that it doesn't have any
negative numbers that depends on your
project and the expectations that you
have about the data
and as you can see testing is all about
automation i have those expectations but
it's best to make sure
that those expectations are true
every time i run my notebook that's the
idea with testing the outputs of your
notebook
once you run your notebook you can have
a function like this and check the
output of the notebook
for example here i'm checking that the
column doesn't have any nas
and that the column doesn't have any
negative numbers
now if something changes here i want to
know because maybe the data changed or
maybe i changed my code and i made some
mistake
you can embed this logic into your
notebook or you can use library we also
have a library called plumber which
allows you to do this essentially having
data quality tests and they run after
you run your notebook so it's a it's a
way of automating um these checkings
all right i'm gonna stop for a few
seconds in case anyone has any questions
okay looks like we're good you'll still
have time to ask me questions at the end
okay
uh now testing notebooks
as i mentioned before
let me go back to here sometimes we have
to define
encapsulate some logic maybe you have a
few functions or classes that
encapsulate some logic
we have to test those as well to make
sure that they are working as we expect
them to do
so there are two approaches here
if you split as i mentioned
the narrative
from the logic then you can import
your logic into a separate file
and then test the implementation this is
approach that i recommend because it
allows you to test things in isolation
and then it also allows you to import
your functions
in any other notebooks and reuse them
right you define them in a single place
and then you bring them to your tests
you bring them to your notebooks and you
only use
one single definition
if you want to implement these you can
use bytest
now there are other approaches as well
if you define if you don't split the
functions from your notebook which is
also fine if you're working on a small
project
and the whole analysis fits well into a
single notebook it's fine to define
those functions i think
the most important
part of organizing your code is
to see what works for you in your
specific use case so i actually
sometimes define um functions inside my
notebooks if i know that i only need
that function for that specific notebook
and maybe i'm running some simple
analysis
so if that applies to you
and you are embedding your functions
inside the notebook you can follow this
second approach
so this library is called testbook
testbook and
it's kind of similar to the other
approach except
you tell the library
where's the notebook that you want to
test so let's assume is this path to nb
dot py and b i pi and b
and then this lobby allows you to
extract certain function
from the notebook so i'm telling this
library
to get me the add1 function inside the
notebook
now this returns me this function and
then i can test it
right it's also it's a good approach if
you already have some
legacy code some existing notebook
this is a good way to get started and
add some tests to your notebooks and
this library has like other features
really nice
and you can you can check it out
all right so now uh we are going to
start talking about the the third
section which is building data pipelines
again if you want to take a deep dive
into the details you can look at our
blog plumber dot io slash blog
slash clean pipelines and and you'll get
more of these details
now before
in one of the previous section i
explained
that having short notebooks helps you a
lot
to make sure that
you can maintain that code and it
doesn't have too much logic
now you might be wondering
how can i come up with a short notebook
if my analysis needs lots of different
parts
well the solution is to build a data
pipeline a data pipeline is essentially
breaking down
the whole data analysis logic into
multiple pieces and then
modifying those pieces in isolation and
making sure that those pieces are able
to communicate with each other
so let's go with the first scenario
where you have all your logic in a
single file maybe it's called
analysis.ip now one important thing is
remember that at the beginning of the
um presentation i mentioned that you can
use pi files as notebooks using juppy
text
now this this same logic applies if you
have an ipnb file or pi file or a
markdown file the same logic applies
okay so let's say you have a really
knock notebook that has two 200 cells it
becomes really hard to maintain you can
represent the same notebook in multiple
small pieces
for example instead of analysis you may
have a load notebook a clean notebook
and a plot notebook
instead of having 200 cells you may be
able to split them into smaller chunks
and at the end of the notebook you store
a file the next notebook loads that file
and then the final notebook loads the
second file
now you can see that by breaking down
this logic it's easier to understand
what's going on because if you show this
to some colleague and they see this they
understand that you have three different
parts and if they are interested in
something specific they can just open
that part and they don't have to read
the other details that might not be
relevant at the moment
now the the other important thing is
that
by breaking down these logic into
multiple files you are bringing
some kind of complexity to your project
because you have to manage multiple
files right that's
that's
why having long notebooks is
sometimes convenient because you just
keep adding code and code and code and
it's convenient because you have
everything there
um but it comes with a lot of
disadvantages
so if you break down the logic you're
yeah you're adding a few a few new files
a few extra logic to store those files
and then load them in the next notebook
but you'll see that it pays in the long
run
now to make it easier for you to build
these kinds of things you can use our
library it's open source
and if you already have legacy notebooks
that look like this you can use another
library that we are working on that
automatically takes this
and converts that into a pipeline so you
save a lot of time you don't have to go
through your code and then create a new
file and copy paste this will do it for
you and then you can start working with
multiple small pieces
all right so um
that's that's all i have um one quick
announcement
we are running a free online course a
longer version of this presentation with
a lot lot many things that i didn't
cover
um you can sign up here
and
you'll learn many many many many tricks
to be able to run a notebooks in
production now if you are interested in
getting these lights you can go to this
url and you'll be able to download them
um so that's that's the
that's all i have i i hope this is
useful and you learn a few tricks and
now you're able to create
a lot more maintainable code and you are
able to deploy those notebooks into
production
and it makes things easier for you
and now if you have any questions maybe
maybe right now they don't come up maybe
tomorrow you can always reach out to me
i'm happy to chat happy to help you
refactor some notebooks or think how you
can apply these practices to your
projects so here's my email feel free
to reach out to me so now um
feel free to ask me any questions